you know it's just so Joe I can remember
back with you and Mike McCarthy yeah it
was like who could work the dirtiest you
guys would be in the back just dying
yeah you know they would can't even get
I'd say let's if we can walk the room
people suck and ever broke but I mean
wait a minute wait wait LA Depp oh my
god I remember one night I was feeling
great and I said dad let me do it I was
[ __ ] up when I turn it on the ground
and then I I felt bad because they were
just so upset so disgusting
and these are like regulars usually come
they started trying to win him back what
about me now and back but there was a
bed a show in Atlanta what it was a guy
heckling me I said listen if you don't
shut up I'm gonna come down and pop you
right in the [ __ ] face and I did I
went I went off the stage and pop this
[ __ ] guy where he was playing then I
mean and the crowd was on his attacking
us and it took me 45 minutes just to
break even you know and then you kept
going after you punch the guy in the
face yeah oh God Lando I don't know what
I know as a later was you know I was
doing a bunch of one-night is in with
and I was because the crowd was a big
crowd but spend like 300 people know I
love Barry and this guy just and I'm
[ __ ] here you know one writer put the
mic never bang anyone down he was
screaming and crying Wow and I went up
in a paper look that's the devil team
Boston in Orlando
yeah you gave me the best advice anybody
ever gave me when I was starting out you
did and right after your brother gave me
the worst advice true Mike told me to
work was good good advice at the time
was smart I liked you I just said Joe I
think maybe you should try to clean it
up a bit yeah and let he comes over [ __ ]
yeah
don't listen to him you were great kid I
love you don't change it thing yeah well
you know that they were you made me
laugh you know because I mean I saw I've
seen everybody I said when I started
doing comedy but 41 years ago there was
only a hundred comedians maybe the whole
country you know what if I heard of
someone I would fly to their town to go
on stage and said let's get out you
don't think Kennison you know and you
know be Slayton in San Francisco you
know people that dumb in Philadelphia
could people I I thought were really
good at it my you know I would like to
see what it is you know yeah became
friends with all them you know that's
awesome and then and then it just blew
up I mean you know now you don't even
have to have an Acura on YouTube or yeah
you still have to have an AK when you
get in front of those live audiences
yeah I think so yeah I've seen those
YouTube guys eat [ __ ] yeah